ich blute er hat das prinzip verstanden
der pool ist ein superhelden-film die so
viele superhelden filme die es jetzt
gibt allerdings ist der mensch nachdem
das team benannt ist nämlich wohl kein
superheld weil das wort super dass ein
bisschen zu klein für ihn er ist er
hyper oder mega oder so was also
grenzenlos und respektlos und regellos
ich wollte nicht super sein und ich bin
kein held aber wenn du mit kriegst er
ist ein schlimmster feind hinter dem
mädchen her ist ist es höchste zeit ein
scheiß superheld zu sein und hält das
wort ist ein bisschen zu groß heute
abend mache ich mir selbst das
dämmmaterial dafür kommt aus den
sechzigern siebzigern schlimmstenfalls
80ern
also denkt dass jemand in allem in
sachen zum teil spiderman während decke
lässt ihn etwas überdrehte rinn und
etwas kokain gestörtem 90ern ground und
so stand auch der film erzählt
holzhammer kiesbett eine sehr niedliche
liebesgeschichte und ansonsten stehen
halt ein horrorfilm ein schriller und
von klassischer superhelden werdegang
einander auf den füßen herum und desto
teilweise wäre es kommt mister wilson
bei ihnen wurde krebs im endstadium
festgestellt was wäre wenn wir sie
heilen und den fähigkeiten verleihen
würden von denen die meisten menschen
nur träumen kann
ach komm schon lässt du mich jetzt ganz
allein mit dieser armseligen catwoman
bisschen gemacht auf den rängen rauen
und sozusagen diese tatsache dass man
wenn man viele verschiedene sachen
miteinander verbinden will eigentlich
ein bisschen finesse braucht und dieser
stoff das nicht hergibt führt dazu dass
es so ganz interessante reibungsverluste
gibt beispielsweise gibt es eine figur
die heißt eigentlich noch hätte
und die hat sich eben selber so genannt
weil wenn teenager superhelden kräfte
hat dann kommt halt irgendeine arbeit
möglichst bombastisch ist und das
einzige was sie mit dem namen machen ist
das deck pool irgendwann sagt boah ist
das ein cooler name während in einem
comic von justine der die avengers
gedreht hatten sehr viel feiner witz
damit gemacht wird als nämlich jemand
der lange nicht mehr über den
superhelden war erfährt wir haben jetzt
jemanden der nennt sich nach sonic team
ico warhead kommt die vollkommen recht
getan wird
uns fallen ich keinen namen mehr ein
oder sie macht der superhelden landung
machte zac
superhelden lange es geht richtig auf
die knie
die schönsten momente sind diese
geschichten momente die schauspielerin
ist nicht zu beneiden oder karin weil
sie ein monster leben muss und einen
riesling lieben muss und jemanden der
einen brocken vernarbtes gesicht hat und
sich dann ein anderes gesicht mit dem
heft klammert acker aufs gesicht tucker
damit besser aussieht und ähnlicher
schärfe scheiße dass ich sehr krass aus
wie ein hoden mit den muss sie aber
nicht mehr lieb haben sondern sie geht
auch einmal so ungefähr ein jahr lang
bedient wird
ich habe viele rollen gespielt jungen
fahren not ist keine davon und sie
keinen fall verkaufen also falls die
leute mal irgendwas verfilmen was echt
nicht geht sollte sie mit moment habe
ich den rettern gelacht unterschied zu
den anderen beiden filmen die beständig
tatsächlich wenn man sich das als so
eine große weihnachtsparty vorstellt wo
die alle sitzen dann ist das so der ein
bisschen schräge kursaal der ab und zu
auch mal aufstoßen muss beim essen und
so aber wir haben trotzdem irgendwie
kennt